>>Hi, I'm Ann Veneman.
I'm the Executive Director of UNICEF.
One of the issues we've been talking about
here at the World Economic
Forum is the issue of Haiti and the devastation
from the earthquake.
Of course, as the United Nations' children's
agency, we are most
concerned about the plight of children.
How does -- how do children get back into
school, for example?
Only 50 percent of the children were going
to school before the
earthquake.
One of the things in the process of rebuilding
the country not only has
to be the investment of businesses here -- those
businesses who are
committed here at Davos -- but also to rebuild
education systems,
health care systems, make sure the children
of Haiti are protected.